what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are finally here we are finally here at
Secret Wars issue number one the start
of Secret Wars 2015 and I am so excited
here I am so psyched because Marvel has
basically taken the axe to all but like
ten people from the earth-616 universe
everybody else is dead it's insane what
they've done here so if you guys recall
in our last video what we had talked
about was that with the incursion
beginning to happen with the incursion
taking place between the earth-616
universe and the ultimate universe that
if one of the planets wasn't destroyed
if one of the earths wasn't destroyed
that both realities are going to be
destroyed entirely and so in response to
this Nick Fury from the Ultimate
Universe launched an invasion against
the earth-616 universe in order to
annihilate the superheroes and destroy
that earth so that both universes could
continue to exist and so this is where
the story picks up the story basically
picks up here where the in care the
invasion is taking place now in the
midst of this invasion we see a
multitude of heroes it's basically all
hands on deck the guardians of the
galaxy are present the x-men are present
Luke Cage iron fist Danny R and Carol
Danvers spider-man the Fantastic Four
all these different characters have all
popped up from all over the planet Earth
to try to stave off this invasion but
what's also taking place here is that
Reed Richards and the Fantastic Four are
trying to organize this multiversal life
raft again this is a life raft that's
basically been designed to house a
certain number of people presumably
around sixty that will allow all these
individuals to survive the collapse of
the multiverse should it take place and
then survive into the next whatever the
next step multiverse happens to be and
so what we find here is that there
eventually comes a point whereby it
seems as though nothing can be done that
too much time has passed it's impossible
to destroy the the earthly ultimate
universe without destroying both earths
in the process simple because of their
proximity and the fact that if the
ultimate universe version of the earth
or if the main earth was destroyed it
would simply just blow up both of them
just due to the fact that the explosion
would be so extreme and so what happens
here is the fan
tastic forum Black Panther effectively
use the the multiversal liferaft to
begin reaching out to the various heroes
that they need that will help them move
on into the next multiverse and so the
following heroes are picked up the
following heroes continue to be part of
what we'll see going into battle world
we see Peter quill joins this team along
with the all-new version all new a
female version of four followed by Peter
Parker spider-man Carol Danvers and
Cyclops who has basically readjusted or
retaken back on the Phoenix force and
this is it this is all we get now of
course this is in addition to the
Fantastic Four and to out Black Panther
but this is really all we see these are
the only characters these about nine or
ten people are the only ones for the
main earth-616 universe that are
presumably going to live on into
whatever this new battle world is going
to be and so what happens here is that
while the group is trying to make their
escape trying to simply survive the
collision of both of these earths that
there's all kinds of electrical storms
there's all kinds of chaos due to the
instability of these realities colliding
with one another and that during this
time these section which basically holds
Susan storm Johnny Storm Ben Grimm and
the Fantastic Four's Children is ripped
away and so what happens is Reed
Richards tries to launch this kind of
rescue attempt in the sense that he
tells T'Challa to lower the shield's now
initially to tell it doesn't want to and
the reason being because if they did it
might cause some kind of an instability
within the ship and it would end up
destroying the multiversal life raft
entirely and so what he says is that
he'll be able to lower it down for five
seconds but after that five seconds is
up if the integrity of the ship goes
below 90% then he's going to have to
raise the shield regardless of what's
happened and so once the shield goes
down Reed Richards tries to reach out to
Susan storm and to grab that section of
the ship but right before he gets there
that section of the ship disintegrates
entirely and so basically Reed Richards
is the only member of the Fantastic Four
left everybody else has been completely
annihilated and so what we find is that
as everything seems to come to an end as
this entire multiverse begins to
collapse and to basically be destroyed
that we see that this multiversal life
raft seems to land
on what this new battle world is I guess
on the the formation of the
conglomeration of all these different
realities that have been merged on to
what battle world is going to be but
again this is what we get we don't
really know what's going to happen next
the only indication we have is from what
Marvel has told us through various
interviews and so on that Secret Wars
issue number two is going to cover all
these different realities but the fact
remains in terms of the earth-616
portion of battle world that is to say
the portion of battle world that's going
to house the characters from that were
previously part of the earth-616
continuity these are the only ones we're
going to see that we're going to see
Reed Richards we're going to see Black
Panther we're going to see Carol Danvers
Cyclops with the Phoenix force Peter
Parker spider-man the only version of
for Peter quill and maybe one or two
other people but that's it this is all
we have left when that being said I
don't know about you guys but that was
one hell of a start to Secret Wars I am
so excited I am so psyched to you I mean
it's it's nuts to see that basically the
entire continuity of Marvel Comics and
the earth-616 except for these nine or
ten characters is gone well that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace